[Music]
all right so last night in this program
we had huge news with the hills John
Solomon breaking the story that the
Justice Department official Bruce or
under oath in congressional testimony
revealing two high-ranking DOJ FBI
officials that Christopher Steele and
his dossier was in fact connected and
paid for by Clinton and very well would
be polluted politically biased our own
Gregg Jarrett now explores the major
legal consequences of this in his new
article entitled out on foxnews.com
Muller's team new dossier kicking off
Trump investigation was biased and
defective here to discuss the details
author of the number one bestseller
Russia hopes the illicit scheme to clear
Hillary Clinton frame Donald Trump Fox
News legal analyst Greg Jarrett and the
author of the best-seller licensed to
lie exposing corruption in the Justice
Department former federal prosecutor
Sidney Powell is back with us alright
Greg let's start with your column and
let's now take a week so in August of
2016
Bruce or warns everybody all the people
in the FBI the upper echelon and DOJ and
DOJ warns them ho
Hillary paid for this bias and
Christopher Steele hates Trump right so
they knew it's paid for about Hillary
Clinton they knew that it's written by a
guy who'd do anything to stop Donald
Trump they should have dropped it
therefore in the trash can they didn't
they thought it was gold we don't care
if it's phony or not we'll use it as a
pretext to frame Donald Russian lies
right paid for okay right so who does
Bruce or tell we've now confirmed I've
been able to confirm as well much of his
deposition testimony he implicates two
top officials at the Department of
Justice who were now on the special
counsels team of partisans and two
others at the FBI who were on it who has
since left so now we've often asked me
why is it Muller investigating the FBI
and the DOJ for Hillary Russian
collusion I think we now know the answer
for people on his own panel were
implicate including one Andrew Weissman
we talked about all the time the knob
Ahmad Andrew Weissman and of course the
infamous Peter struck Lisa page all four
Oh better on yeah they all new in the
summer of 2016 that this thing was
suspect so if he's supposedly looking at
Russian interference hillary pays for
russian lies about our opponent that
they are peddling right even we have our
own Intel community peddling to the
American people right so they do it to
steal an election then they do it to get
a FISA warrant you know what everyone
talk why it doesn't and why aren't any
of these people ever investigated
where's the grand jury when is somebody
gonna do their job because you had the
incompetent and feckless Jeff Sessions
in charge and Rod Rosenstein who signed
off on one of the FISA warrants
improperly he knew it was bought and
paid he's been at not verified he's been
obstructing ever since so sessions is
gone
Rosa Stein will soon be gone William Bar
will become the Attorney General and I'm
fairly confident he will investigate if
he doesn't then we're a Banana Republic
Sydney let me go to you you know a lot
about Andrew Weissman because you wrote
about him he's Mahler's pit bull now he
knew about this and they're looking into
Russia collusion and they'd never
touched this Sean I'm sure mr. Weissman
was very involved in it he might have
even helped draft the FISA applications
he would have known about it from the
first conversation he had with
Christopher Steele I mean this kind of
fabrication is right up mr. Weissman's
alley as you know from reading license
to lie yourself he's very good at making
up crimes and making up the factual
narrative he wants to suit whatever
crime he wants to charge that's a
standard operating procedure shows
people are innocent because remember
Bruce or after Steel's fired for lying
and leaking by the FBI they still wanted
more contact with him his contact was
Bruce War and they're writing about we
have Christopher Steele who built this
lying phony dossier
that's debunked now giving information
to Bruce or to funnel to the special
counsel Robert Moore himself we have
that evidence oh yes yes and I think it
goes back far
than that Sean I think it goes back to
2015 when Comey gave illegal access to
the raw NSA data to three private
contractors I would bet that one of
those is fusion GPS and that they were
mining that data to create this phony
dossier with Christopher Steele in the
first place so fulfilled it through him
two years has been Trump Russia and they
knew from the get-go that Hillary paid
for Russian lies that were disseminated
to the American people and then they use
those lies that they knew or lies never
verified it if they would have done
their job they sign off it as gospel
truth to get a warrant shred the
Constitution shred the Fourth Amendment
to spy on a trump campaign associate and
they're the people in charge of looking
into Russian collusion exactly they lied
to the FISA Court and mr. Rosenstein son
the applications mr. Comey son the
applications there are others who son
those applications as well whose names
have been redacted we need to know who
those people are the investigation that
mr. Muller started should have been of
those people and never of the Trump
campaign at all it's egregious
government misconduct the Muller
witch-hunt should be ended immediately
and the entire I don't know Shawn I mean
I'm I'm still concerned about mr. Baris
personal relationship with mr. Muller so
am i you're not now look the bottom line
here is there was no Trump collusion but
there was Hillary FBI Department of
Justice collusion and for people on
Muller Special Counsel team involved and
also we know that they literally lied to
the FISA Court and committed fraud all
right